Good morning everybody.
We have talked in the course of the semester many times about the Hellenization
of Roman architecture,
about the impact that Greek architecture had on Roman architecture.
And we've talked in particular about the to fill Hellenic emperors Augustus and
also Hadrian and the kinds of monuments they commissioned during their rain.
Uh,
that was so clearly based on those in ancient Athens,
Athens,
especially if the classical period cradle of civilization and where one,
some when when we're,
we're a scholars often speak of as the birth of democracy.
I want to turn full circle,
go full circle here and return to the whole question of Athens by looking at
Athens itself.
Because Athens also became a Roman colony.
I,
and you won't be surprised to hear that it was built up under primarily to Roman
emperors,
namely Augustus and Hadrian justice.
One would expect the two major fill Hellenic Roman emperors.
I show you a spectacular view of Athens as it looks today.
Uh,
and you can see here,
uh,
that the city of Athens,
and it's,
uh,
some of it's antiquities extremely well preserved,
is a city that is located.
It's actually a city that's located in planes surrounded by mountains,
uh,
and it also has three major hills is I think you can see from this extraordinary
image.
Uh,
one of those hills of course,
is the famous Acropolis.
And I think by the way,
if one were to make,
I don't know how many of you have been to Athens,
but if one were to make a list of the 10 places that one really must see at some
point during their lives and experience,
Athens is certainly one of them,
mainly for the Acropolis,
which you see in the center of this image here.
That's one of the major,
uh,
hills.
The other two are Mount Lee Cabi toss,
which you see in the upper most part.
That's actually the highest hill of Athens.
And then there's another one called the [inaudible] hill,
which we're going to actually talk about today because there's an important
monument there.
The Jose on hail or the hill of the muses.
It's located off this image right where I'm standing here.
And those three hills,
uh,
as you can see,
rise up in the city of Athens.
And it's not surprising.
And the rest of it surrounded essentially by a city that was constructed
primarily after World War II,
mainly residential houses of six,
five,
six stories,
residences,
uh,
that are,
that are mostly white in color as I think you can see here.
But the Acropolis rising up in the center in an amazing way,
uh,
the city of Athens,
um,
we know,
uh,
was,
was founded in the Neolithic period I was found in the Neolithic period.
So it goes way back in the same way that Rome does.
And it's not surprising to see them founding the city of Athens on one of those
hills.
And which he'll did,
they pick,
they pick the hill,
that's the flattest,
which makes it easiest to build on.
And that is the rock of the Acropolis itself.
So they put their religious structures on the Acropolis.
And then over time,
uh,
the city begins to grow up around the rock of the Acropolis.
Now this is very interesting because if you think back to Rome and its
beginnings,
you'll recall that Rome too,
was founded on a hill because hills can be most readily fortified.
So Rome was founded,
you'll recall on essentially on two hills on the Palatine hill by Romulus where
he established residences,
but also on the Capitol on hill where they built the temple of Jupiter,
optimist mocks and Ms Capitol Lena.
So that being the religious center of the city,
we see the same sort of thing happening here.
Uh,
the city growing up on the Acropolis.
And then we'll see that the meeting in marketplace is down below,
uh,
the in the valley below the Acropolis in the same way that the Roman forum or
what became the Roman forum was in the valley beneath the Palatine hill and also
the capital line hale in Rome.
So very similar beginnings of four briefs as also for Rome.
As you all know,
uh,
Athens thrive,
particularly Greece in general,
thrive particularly in the fifth century BC under Paris,
Lees and continued to thrive into the Hellenistic period.
Uh,
but it was an 86 BC that Sala,
the Roman General Sela,
uh,
sacked Athens,
made Athens a Roman colony and in fact destroyed the walls of the city of
Athens.
So that a very obviously a very major point in the history of Athens when when
scholars talk about architecture that was put up by the Romans in Athens during
Roman times,
they talk about it as being primarily uninspired and rather derivative.
And you'll find this in your textbook.
Ward Perkins talks about how derivative,
uh,
Roman architecture in Greece is of its earlier counterparts that is from
classical and Hellenistic Athens.
And I think he has a point and it's something that we should all think about as
a group,
whether we think that the buildings that we look at today are for the most part
derivative from the classical and Hellenistic past.
But I think to say only that is to miss the point in part because what we are
also going to see as we look at these buildings today is that the extraordinary
marbles that come from this part of the world,
Greek marbles,
and we'll talk about a number of them today,
the quality of those is so high or that it's hard to imagine any building made
out of these.
Not spectacular just for the materials alone and also because the artists and
the architects and the artisans who were responsible for carving this marble had
been carving it for centuries.
And consequently they were particularly skilled at carbon marble.
And so what they produced has great beauty as I think you'll see today.
Uh,
so those two,
again,
a very important point,
I believe about the quality of these works of art and we're also going to see
works of architecture.
We're also going to see that at least two of them in my opinion,
are really distinctive.
A structure is different than anything we've seen before.
Uh,
and I think that you'll find they're quite innovative in their own way.
And we will look at,
as I said,
both of those,
um,
today,
uh,
the city of Athens began to be excavated by archeologists in the 1930s.
And those excavations,
which were scientific,
very careful scientific excavations,
those excavations combined with information that we have from a writer of the
Greco Roman past,
a man by the name of [inaudible],
p a,
U s a n I a s palisade Aeneas,
who was a Greek of the second century,
a d who traveled around Greece and described everything that he saw.
And He created in essence,
a guidebook to the great Greek and Roman antiquities.
The combination of his descriptions from the second century firsthand
descriptions of the monuments that stood in the second century along with the
scientific excavations of the 1930s.
And since,
uh,
allow us to get an excellent sense of what,
not only what,
as we look at the remains today,
not only of what was there is there now and was there once upon a time,
but what these buildings actually were their identities,
uh,
and,
what their function was in Athens,
either in Greek or in Roman times.
And we will use the information provided by both of those today,
uh,
to allow us to reconstruct the city,
the Roman city in particular.
Now the building,
as you could see from the view of the Acropolis,
uh,
there are a number of Greek structures on the top of the Acropolis and I'll show
them to you later.
These include the great Greek entryway of the fifth century BC,
the so called [inaudible],
the famous Parthenon of course,
the small temple of Athena Nikkei,
uh,
and also the Eric theone,
which is the only building we've really discussed in any detail in the course of
this semester of fifth century BC building.
You see it here in an extraordinary view.
Now on the screen,
the Eric Theone,
which we believe was built sometime between about four 21 and 406 BC.
And the reason that it's important is not because it's an incredible example,
a fifth century Greek architecture,
but also because of the buildings up on the Acropolis.
It is the one that seems to have captured the imagination,
uh,
of,
of Augustus and also Hadrian when both of them visited the city of Athens,
uh,
but also of the Romans as a whole.
And you'll remember the reason for that is essentially a,
the porch of the maidens,
which you can see so well in this view,
uh,
the portrait of the maidens that exerted a very strong impact on a Augustus and
Hadrian.
Before I talk a little bit more about the portrait the maidens though,
just something about,
uh,
the rest of the construction that you can see as you look at the columns that
they are of the ionic order,
a particularly attractive and elegant version of the ionic order with the ionic
capitals,
with they're very attractive volumes.
Uh,
you can also see the materials that are used here.
What you can see is what's used for the foundations.
That material is called Poor Oss,
p o r o s porous use for the foundations of the Eric theone and also many other
of the buildings that we'll look at today.
And then,
uh,
most out,
most importantly,
the most of the building,
the walls and the columns are made out of pentelic marble,
pentelic marble,
which is from Mt.
Penn Telecon in Greece,
and is the marble that is used most often for,
uh,
for buildings in Athens,
both in Greek times and also enrollment times as we shall see today.
And it's characterized by being gleaming white,
really blindingly white as one looks at it in the very bright,
uh,
Greek son against the Blue Sky,
with regard to the courtyard and porch,
the porch of the maidens,
very famous portrait of the maidens.
You'll recall that both Augustus and Hadrian visited Athens.
They both saw this monument.
The Eric theone had fallen into disrepair,
uh,
by the age of Augustus.
And Augustus was so admiring of this porch that he made the decision to have his
own architects and artisans come to Athens to repair the porch.
Uh,
and they not only repaired the maidens themselves,
but also replaced one.
One was in such bad shape.
I think it was the one in the back,
right?
It was in such bad shape,
uh,
that they,
restored that one entirely.
When they were there looking at those maintenance,
restoring them.
Uh,
they were so taken by them that they made plaster casts of those and they
brought them back to Rome.
And you'll recall that they were used in Rome as the models,
uh,
for,
maidens that were put up.
Here's,
here's a view of course,
of those on the Acropolis from the front.
Uh,
they made reduced scale copies for the forum of Augustus in Rome.
The second story of the forum of Augustus as you'll,
uh,
and then down here you'll be reminded of the chorionic heads,
also based on those of the Eric theone in this case to scale,
same scale as those in Athens use to line the Chronopolis of Hadrian's villa at
Tivoli.
So both emperors,
again,
Augustus and Hadrian very admiring of these works of art and wanted copies of
them for,
in Augustus's case,
a public structure in Rome,
in Hadrian's case,
a private villa at Tivoli.
And we even believe that heroic Atticus and the tomb that he made for Ani
Radilla in Rome,
that brick tomb,
the second century id on the via Apia,
uh,
there were two female figures that were found near excavated near that tomb and
it has been suggested that they too may belong to that tomb.
And while they are variations rather than copies,
you can see that they too owe their origins to the choreography.
So this building,
the Eric Theone,
uh,
cast a spell on Augustus in Hadrian and was widely imitated in Rome.
What we're going to see today is that this building continued to have a very
strong impact also on the buildings that these same emperors Augustus in Hadrian
put up in Athens itself.
Before we look at Athens,
I want to take a very short,
uh,
short trip to another city,
the city of Elusiveness,
e l e u s,
I s,
the city of elusive in Greece,
a because I want to make one more point about the [inaudible] and about the
important exchange that we believe was going on between Rome and Athens already
in the late says Arion period.
And into the age of Augustus.
Augustus is sending his architects,
uh,
but we think we think they are going back and forth.
And that there is an important exchange of,
uh,
building techniques as well as architectural ideas that is happening between
Rome and Greece in the age of Augustus,
a looseness.
And you see what it looks like today,
uh,
is a,
is a hilly town that is located not too far from Athens.
And it was particularly popular in the Greek period because are particularly
important in the Greek period,
uh,
because it had a sanctuary of the goddess Demeter,
the goddess Demeter and the goddess Demeter are surrounding her was this very
important mystery religion.
The so called Elliot Eleusinian mysteries after Hallucis Eleusinian mysteries,
uh,
that took place here.
And people came from far and wide to partake of those Eleusinian mysteries.
And so the city was built up in classical and Hellenistic Greek times.
It also remained important,
uh,
in the time of Caesar and into the time of Augustus and a DC and actually into
the the and second centuries a d and over time decisions were made to add to the
sanctuary of Demeter by the Roman emperors and generals and also at the s and
using of course the service of their only architects,
architects from Rome,
but working in concert with those in Greece.
And one of the,
one of the decisions that they made was to provide the sanctuary of Demeter with
two additional gateways and inner gateway and an outer gateway.
The outer gateway,
which is the larger of the two was put up in the second century,
a by the and nine emperors.
But the earlier one,
the inner inner or smaller gateway was put up already in 50 BC.
So,
uh,
at the late Republican period put up in 50 BC.
And uh,
there are some remains of it enough that we can come up with quite good
reconstructions of what it looked like.
And I want to show you those fairly quickly in passing just because they
underscore this important connection that is going on between Rome and Greece.
In this period.
We see,
uh,
one,
one side.
This gateway actually has two sides and we see one side of it here,
uh,
with columns and a quite traditional pediment above the triglycerides.
And met a ps that you see here have representations of sheaves of wheat and what
are called Cysteine,
which are baskets.
Uh,
both of which have to do with the Elo,
Sydney and mysteries and the worship of Demeter.
But what's most interesting for us,
and it may be a little hard for you to make this out and the risk in this
reconstruction,
but what's interesting for us are the capitals because the capital's are
examples of the so-called zoomorphic capital's that we've seen before,
capitals in which,
uh,
the upper parts of the bodies of animals,
take to take the place of the spirals and grow out of the campus leaves.
And I can show you a one was one preserved example from hallucis over here on
the left hand side of the screen made out of pentelic marble.
Uh,
we see it here and you can see the uh,
campus leaves and you can see a part of the upper part of a bull that is growing
out of a bull proteome that is growing out of the canvas leaves.
That should remind you of something we saw a much earlier in the semester.
Does anyone remember where this capital comes from?
I know you all know
not the forum transitory.
I'm know the forum of Augustus,
the forum of Augustus.
I had these capitals,
some of these capitals that included Pega,
sy growing out of the canvas leaves.
So this suggests to us this whole idea of having animals growing out of the
canvas leaves,
uh,
it,
you know,
roughly not exactly at the same time,
but roughly in the same periods is Aaron peered into the Gustin period suggests
that ideas were floating back and forth between Athens and Rome in the time of
Caesar and in the time of Augustus.
Now,
if we look at the other side of the gate,
we see something that would seem to confirm that even more.
And that is on the other side.
[inaudible] replace the columns with their zoomorphic capitals.
These are not,
as you can clearly see,
you see how they have their hands up.
They are not based exactly on those of the Eric theone porch.
They are variations of that,
but they are carry out.
Its nonetheless holding the capitals on top of their heads.
Uh,
so we are seeing here even in even as grease becomes,
it becomes Roman,
uh,
in this is area period and into the age of Augustus even as grease becomes Roman
will,
it already does as I mentioned to you before,
when Sola Saxon and 86 BC.
So in 50,
it's already a Roman colony.
Uh,
and so we can see the,
these ideas that are,
that are going back and forth,
uh,
between Rome and Greece during this important period.
And we see the power of the [inaudible] even in Greece itself as they are
imitated there as well.
Uh,
from this point on,
for the rest of the lecture,
I do want to concentrate on Athens.
Uh,
and I want to begin again with the Acropolis.
This is actually a very interesting Google earth image of the Acropolis where
you can see as it looks today,
but where you can see super imposed on the current car.
On the Co,
the president remains a three d versions of the ancient buildings.
And we can see the ones that I've already mentioned.
Uh,
as you enter over here,
you see the group Greek propylene hub of the fifth century BC,
the entrance gate.
Uh,
you see the Parthenon,
which is the largest building,
a dork building on top of the Acropolis.
And then to it's left eye,
you see the Eric Theone,
uh,
and in the back,
the remains of a museum that,
I mean not the remains a museum or that is in part underground,
which is why it looks so flat that houses the original car,
he audits and a lot of other sculpture.
The ones that you see on the porch today are,
are copies of those originals that are in the museum as well as other sculpture
that was found on the Acropolis.
And you can also see here the Odi on the parolees.
Atticus,
which I have mentioned to you with the Yani concert took place on the slope of
the Acropolis here.
And then you can also see a theater.
You see the theater in this corner right here,
which is interesting because we believe at dates to the neurone Ian period,
which is interesting because you'll remember that Nero competed in the Olympic
Games and that he came to Greece to compete in the Olympic Games.
So it's not surprising even though we don't think of him as one of the Great
Phil Hellenic emperor is not surprising to see that.
There was some construction in Greece during the Neronian period.
I want to turn to what's interesting actually about what the Romans do in the
age of Augustus when Augustus goes up here himself,
sends his architects to repair the porch,
is a decision is made to build a little shrine to Augustus and to Rome,
to a temple,
to Augustus and Roma,
and they decide to put it in the back left corner,
uh,
of the,
of the Parthenon.
And you can barely see it there,
but it's a small round building at the upper most part of the Parthenon between
that and the museum.
And I'm going to show it to you in detail in a moment,
and they build that from scratch,
but they also take a pillar that is located right at the beginning of a right in
front of the proper Alayah that was put up in Hellenistic times and they
transform that into a Roman monument.
And it's those two to those two that I want to turn first.
This is Google earth again.
You can see the Parthenon,
the Eric theone in these three d versions.
Can you see just that little,
you know,
that round circle right next to the edge of the,
uh,
of the Parthenon that is the temple of Augustus in Roma.
And the fact that it is so small I think is strikingly interesting,
uh,
because it shows that although Augustus was willing to have a building put up to
himself and to Roma on the Greek Acropolis and he,
so he wanted to make his presence known,
he did it in a very modest,
uh,
and very respectful way.
It seemed to be you could have built a much larger than he did and he opted not
to do that,
which,
which tells us something about Augustus and perhaps his reverence for things
Greek.
Uh,
we are looking at two views of what survives of this small round shrine.
actually quite a bit.
I mean it's not standing any longer,
but you can see parts of columns and parts of the curved in tablature,
curved architrave and,
and some of the other building elements very clearly here,
including one of the capitals.
Again,
it was around structure.
It had nine ionic columns.
It had,
it was made entirely out of stone and it had a sloping stone roof.
And this restored view shows us exactly what it looked like as well as how small
it was in relationship to the Parthenon,
which absolutely dwarfs it.
And scale,
as you can see in this restored view,
I hear this,
the small temple of Augustus enrollment was built sometime after 27 BC and you
see it here,
ionic capitals,
uh,
and then a sloping stone roof.
Uh,
and if I show you the remains again,
where you can see one of those ionic capitals still preserved here.
And we compare that ionic capital to the ionic capitals of the Eric theone in
Athens on the Acropolis.
We see the close resemblance between the two.
And the reason for this,
almost certainly that because Augustus is architects,
we're working on the Eric theone,
we're restoring it,
were repairing it.
They were captivated not just by the car he audits,
but also by the rest of the,
uh,
of the structure,
by the quality of the Mirabelle,
by the attractiveness of the,
uh,
of the ionic columns with their cat,
with their spiral volumes.
At the top,
and they not surprisingly use those as the model for the capitals that they
carved for the small shrine of the temple of Augustus and Roma.
But I think it also shows their reverence for things Greek and their desire to
establish a dialogue,
uh,
between the fifth century BC structure and the Roman structure built right after
Augustus became emperor.
I wanted to mention one other material that is used in the Eric theone.
We talked about the poor us for the foundations,
the pentelic marble for the walls and the columns.
But if you look here,
you'll see the slight blue cast to the marble that is used for the freeze that
is so called Eleusinian marble from that part,
from the elusive area of Greece,
Eleusinian marble with a slightly blue cast,
and that is used in the Eric theone as well.
I mentioned that the,
the temple of Roma and Augustus was put up.
AW was built from scratch.
It was,
there was nothing there before and it was built a new,
uh,
during the Augustan period.
Uh,
but I also noted that there was another monument that we could call a Roman
intervention to the Acropolis.
Uh,
that wasn't,
was actually already there,
but was transformed in Roman times.
And I show it to you now.
Here we are making our way with all of these other tourists,
uh,
up to the rock of the,
to the top of the rock of the Acropolis.
We've climbed up the stairway,
which is not at all,
it's not particularly steep.
We've made our way up.
We're about to enter into the group Greek proper layer of the fifth century BC.
No,
the doric columns,
the try glyphs and metaphase of fifth century Greek architecture.
And we see next to it,
this pillar.
It's a very interesting pillar.
It's very prominent.
It's the first thing you see when you enter the Acropolis.
So it's whoever built this initially wanted to be noticed,
that's for sure.
Uh,
and we know it was a Hellenistic king,
a Hellenistic king by the name of humanities,
e u.
M e n e s human needs.
The second,
uh,
who was king of the Hellenistic Greek Kingdom of Pergamon are g,
g a m U M R o,
n with you use the Greek or the Latin spelling.
Pergamon.
Uh,
and uh,
he commissioned this monument in 178 BC to honor himself.
And you can see that the purpose of the monument was to create this pillar upon
which a statue of him would have been placed.
And I show you the pillar once again here,
and you can see its shape.
It has a stepped base and it tapers at the top and you have to imagine a,
a statue of human needs.
The second a Pergamon on the top of this monument in the second century BC.
And it was altered in the first century BC when Marcus Agrippa,
the close childhood friend,
confidant,
righthand man of,
uh,
Augusta son in law in fact,
decided to replace the statute of human needs with one of himself.
So he transforms this Greek Hellenistic monument into and Augustan Monument and
Augustan monument that honors a gripper and a grip.
It's not surprising to see a grip,
a honored in the east.
He was involved in eastern military campaigns.
And we'll also see that he not only,
uh,
he,
he not only,
and I mentioned this earlier in the semester,
he not only had a building,
he not only re re,
uh,
renovated,
he not only instituted a building program in Rome,
he was responsible for the so called Bas,
have a grip of that bear.
His name not much is preserved.
So I didn't show those to you.
Uh,
and also,
uh,
a pantheon,
the first pantheon that I did mention the Pantheon,
the grip of belt that's referred to in the inscription that Hadrian,
uh,
placed on the Pantheon.
Marcus a grip of made this building as you'll recall,
the pantheon that we know had a chorionic porch.
So Agrippa in Rome is also carrying the carotid imagery into Rome and his
building,
his building a program.
But he also instituted a building program in Athens as we shall see.
So it's very important.
It was not surprising to see him honored along with Augustus on the Acropolis.
And actually in a way that that was much more noticeable to be hit by that
statue of a grip as you climbed the Acropolis and went into the prop Alayah a
must have been very striking indeed.
Uh,
this particular structure is made of a different kind of Greek marble called
high nation marvel,
I a n from Mount High Medis [inaudible] marble.
You can see a little bit of pentelic here,
but much of it is high mation marble.
So the Romans using the Greeks and the Romans using a variety of marbles,
but a variety of marbles that come from Greece itself.
We're not talking about imported marbles from elsewhere in the ancient world.
I mentioned already that below the Acropolis was the Greek Agora Ra or the
meeting or marketplace.
I showed to you here a view from Google earth of the Greek Agora.
As it looks from the air today,
you can see it as essentially an open rectangular space.
It has colonnades,
uh,
on some of its sides.
One set,
one set was ray erected.
This is a,
um,
a structure,
a covered call,
an aid that comes from the,
from the Hellenistic period that was redirected by American archeologists who
were responsible for excavating Jaeger Ra.
They redirected it in part to use as a place to display works art and for
offices and so on.
Uh,
but there were more,
it was more than one in Romanesque,
in,
um,
in Greek times.
[inaudible].
This steaua is the counterpart to a Roman Portico covered colonnade,
uh,
but they called them stolen.
So we look at the Steaua here from the Hellenistic period.
There's a classical Greek temple,
the HEPA stay on over here.
Uh,
but,
uh,
and in the center there was a building,
a called the musical that was built by Marcus Agrippa,
the so called Odeon of a grip,
uh,
that we know quite a bit about and that we're going to look at today.
But again,
what's particularly interesting,
I think is the fact that we see the Greeks building their religious structures
on the Acropolis and then down below the meeting and marketplace.
And you can see the impact that this sort of thinking must have had on the
Romans when they made their own decisions about building Roman forums.
But there are distinct differences and we've talked about them already this
semester between a a Greek Agora and a Roman forum.
What Greek Agora Ra's do not have is that central that that focus of having a
single temple on one end dominating the space in front of it and they're more
square.
Whereas Roman forms,
as we've discussed,
are more rectangular in shape with again,
the temple at the short end.
Any of you who've been to Athens know that the Agora Ra is surrounded by an area
of Athens called Placa Pla k Placa a great place,
a fun place to go.
It has been very gentrified in recent years and now has these wonderful pastel
colored,
uh,
restaurants and shops with the ubiquitous white umbrella is just as you see them
in other Mediterranean countries like Italy.
I lived in,
in Athens for two years in the 1970s.
Uh,
and uh,
placa did not look like that then.
Uh,
but it was an incredible place to go.
Then is it still is now if you want to really get into the Greek spirit and
dance on tables and break plates,
you could definitely do that in the 70s,
a little less ubiquitously today,
but there's still places that one can find to sort of play Zorba the Greek in
um,
in placa.
Uh,
here is another view,
a panoramic view showing once again the Agora,
the Greek Agora of Athens as it would've looked as it grew up from the classical
through the Hellenistic period.
But the building in question for us is the one that is smack in the middle of
the Greek temple and of the Hellenistic Steaua over here.
And that is this music hall or Odi on of a grip up,
uh,
which was put up,
we believe in around 15 BC.
And it's to that structure that I want to turn now.
And this,
this building,
this Oh,
on which a grip,
a commission to himself is very important to us in large part because it
demonstrates that ideas were not only flowing from Greece to Rome,
as we've already discussed today and in the past,
but from Italy to Greece.
And this is a prime example of that because if we look at this accident metric
view of the [inaudible] of a grip as designed for a gripper and 15 BC,
and this is in Ward Perkins,
if we look at that,
we will see that the plan of the Dion of Agrippa is exam is based very closely
on an Odi on that we've already seen this semester,
the Odi on of palm pay.
You'll see it here from the air next to the theater of Pompei.
You'll remember that the Odi on a pay data to 80 to 70 BC,
it was quite early.
Bill,
just after the Romans made Pompei pay into a colony.
And it is that exact plan that is used here.
So clearly,
again,
an important exchange going on of ideas of architects.
Uh,
between Greece and Rome in the Augustan period.
And,
uh,
in this case,
using a,
an Italian plan,
a plan from Italy,
uh,
as the basis for a structure in Greece.
We see that it follows in the May,
it follows all the features of the palm pay in structure.
The semicircular orchestra,
the cabi divided into Kunae,
a stage front here,
uh,
pilasters on a tall pilasters on some of the walls and open steaua on this wall.
Over here you can see two sets of columns and in a row and an outer row,
we know that the spectators entered the structure through this porch when they
were coming to a musical recital.
And over here there was another entrance way that was used by the part,
by the musicians and also by visiting dignitaries.
This was a smaller entrance way that was made up of a small temple front with a
pediment,
uh,
and a doric columns,
here.
And,
uh,
we can also see tall pilasters on the outside of this structure.
And of course,
this building as all,
uh,
oh,
dia was roofed in antiquity for the acoustics.
And the one in palm pay was of course also roofed,
another view across section of the,
uh,
of the Odeon of a gripper.
You can see it here,
which shows you the same sort of thing.
The tall pilasters on the outside of the structure,
the entrance way through this steaua,
uh,
for the,
for the spectators,
the other entrance way over here,
the smaller entrance way into that part of the structure.
All very well shown.
And maybe in this may even be better,
this model of the Odi on have a grip of where we can see what it looked like
from the outside.
We're looking at the northern end,
which is the end where we have that small and prince way,
uh,
with the um,
with very simple temple like,
uh,
in,
in appearance,
uh,
we can see a series of columns engaged into the wall down here than the very
tall pilasters with windows,
uh,
between them,
quite conventional building.
Uh,
but one again,
clearly base and this is the most important point that one can make about it
clearly based on,
uh,
an earlier model in Italy.
The capitols are interesting.
You remember the Stowe is that I the two open,
uh,
colonnades that I showed you as one stop,
one wall at one side of the building,
the inner one and the outer one.
Uh,
the,
um,
I'm going to forget which way the outer,
the outer one,
I believe.
No,
the outer one I think is the,
they're two different orders.
One of them is Corinthian as you can see here.
I think that's the outer,
but I may have that backwards.
Uh,
the one of them had Corinthian capitals and you see those here,
uh,
with the,
narrow,
the elegant volume.
It's growing out of the elegant spirals growing out of the canvas leaves.
And the other is of this type A,
a type that we have seen before,
but not frequently where we have lotus leaves growing out of the canvas leaves.
Uh,
and that of course is a kind of capital that we mentioned is inspired by
capitols in Egypt and was used also much later in,
much later times at the forum at leftest Maga,
the Sephora and forum at leftest magma.
So a type of,
of,
um,
of capital that is a key characteristic of Egypt that turns up here.
So it's another example of the way in which these architects and patrons are
looking at models from all over the world,
not only the Odi on,
uh,
in palm pay,
but also structures from Egypt and combining those motifs in a very,
in a new,
in a new way,
in a very fertile mix.
As you can see
with regard to the later history of the Odi on have a grip on over the years,
students sometimes have asked me,
I haven't heard,
gotten this question this semester yet,
but,
uh,
students have asked me or have said to me,
professor Kleiner,
you show us in the course of this semester,
uh,
all of these great works of Roman engineering and architecture,
the Pantheon and the coliseum,
an aqua ducks and so on and so forth.
And everything you do tell us about fires.
It fires sometimes destroy these works of art,
or there were works of architecture or they're destroyed because of other
natural events,
like events of nature,
like earthquakes and so on.
But you never tell us,
uh,
about the buildings that failed.
Did where the Roman architects always successful or did they build buildings?
Sometimes it filled out.
Uh,
and so I always use this as an example because yes,
they sometimes did make mistakes and some of their buildings did collapse.
And this is one of them,
the Odi on of a grip after it was viewed and described by posts.
Sinneas uh,
the roof collapsed,
collapsed entirely.
Now it lasted quite a while,
uh,
from,
um,
uh,
the time of Augustus to the time to the second century of Palestinians.
But nonetheless,
the roof collapsed entirely and the roof had to be completely rebuilt.
I,
and at the same time,
the decided to modernize the northern end of the structure and to add a new
portico,
uh,
to the building.
Uh,
they also changed its use,
by the way,
from an Odi on to a general lecture hall.
Uh,
during that period.
So in 150 a d we see that the,
uh,
that the northern end is completely redundant.
It's interesting to see what they decided to do or they replace that very small
conservative doric entryway with something with a lot more pazazz.
As you can see,
a series of,
of male figures.
These are male tritons trit oh,
and s tritons,
which are essentially male mermaids.
Uh,
male tried tones,
tightens and are essentially male mermaids on these tall decorated basis as you
can see here.
And their,
their,
uh,
their gestures are mirror images of one another or reversed images of one
another,
which creates a certain liveliness to the facade,
to the northern facade that this building did not have before.
And that happened again in the mid second century.
And,
and interestingly enough,
uh,
much of what survives today,
is,
are those tried tons.
You can still see them on their bases here on their tall bases are part of them
here.
And you can see the relationship of the Odi on of Agrippa in this very good
image to the Acropolis in Athens.
You can see the Eric theone peeping up over there.
You can see the great pedestal that a grip of would have had his statue on right
here.
So I'm very tempted to say,
in fact,
I will say that I don't think that was lost on the designers,
that when they chose this spot for the,
uh,
Oh Deon and a grip,
but they had very much in mind that it could,
would be in one of these interesting architectural dialogues,
uh,
with the,
with the pedestal that had the statue of a grip on,
at,
at the entrance way to the Acropolis.
I think that was certainly very carefully orchestrated in the same way you'll
remember Julius Caesar and his architects orchestrated a relationship between
the temple of Venus Gannett trucks,
uh,
and the temple of Jupiter Omc on the,
on the Capitoline hill in Rome.
And despite the fact that you see,
when you visit the Agora,
the Greek Agora today,
and look at these statutes,
despite the fact that they are all that stands,
there's a lot.
You will see that there are lots of other remains on the ground.
And with those remains and the excavations that were done by the American
archeologists in the 1930s,
uh,
they are,
the reconstruction that we looked at from ward Perkins,
we believe is a very accurate reconstruction of what the ODN of a grip.
I looked like.
I want to look at the Roman ag rob,
because the Romans ed themselves added an Agora to Athens.
If they were going to have a Greek Agora,
they would have a Roman Agora.
We don't know if there was a practical need for it,
but I guess Caesar Augustus wanted to emblazon their name on an aggregate on an
Agora or marketplace in Athens.
It was put up again in [inaudible] and started in the [inaudible] area and
period and completed by Augustus.
It is right near the Greek Agora.
We see a view of adhere a large open rectangular space with a colonnade around
it.
Uh,
in this case,
Stowers,
we would call these Stowers and the Greek context with tobacco and I or ma or
shops at the upper most part,
uh,
and entrance way and elaborate entrance way on the western end and another
entrance way on the,
uh,
on the uh,
eastern end.
But as you can see,
it differs.
It is,
it is done in the mode of a Greek market place because it is more,
well,
it's sort of in between a square and a rectangle here.
It's not quite,
it's not as low as long as a Roman forum and it does not have a,
a temple on one short end and that,
so it follows in the mode of Greek Agora Roz rather than a Roman four up the,
you can see if you look at Google Earth,
uh,
one can see,
the forum today,
the Roman,
here's the sto of adults and the Greek Agora Ross.
And you can see its proximity to this new Roman Agora that was added.
We're looking at that open space here with the colonnades.
We're looking at the western entrance way as well as the eastern entrance.
Way Up above,
uh,
in this very helpful view.
And this is a view I took from the Acropolis,
looking down on the,
uh,
on the,
Roman Agora raw and showing the back of the western entrance way,
which I'll show you from the front and a moment.
And there you can see placa actually pre gentrification.
Uh,
it gives you a sense of what,
I mean,
it was really crumbling as you can see with some of the buildings that are
surrounding it.
But nonetheless,
it was fun.
Uh,
so here we go.
this is a view of the,
uh,
of the gate.
Uh,
it's called the gate of Athena Arcadis's.
You can see on your monument list,
uh,
that is the western gate into the Roman Agora.
We see it here in two views.
And you can see when you look at this building,
you can see what ward Perkins and other others mean when they say that
architecture in Greece,
a under the row in Athens under the Romans is derivative and uninspired.
Uh,
it's this kind of thing that I believe he's talking about because you can see
how beholden it is too.
Traditional classical Greek architecture in the way in which we see these great
doric columns looking very similar to those of the pro Bellayo or the or the
Parthenon.
You see them here,
you see the triangle of sin,
metaphase,
you see a,
a,
a triangular pediment.
We never see,
we never see the Greeks,
at least the Greeks in the Roman period,
uh,
breaking their pediments,
they always have a complete pediments.
And then that sense,
of course,
very,
very conservative approach to architecture during this period.
We know that this,
the gate was begun by Caesar completed by,
and there's an inscription that tells us that,
uh,
and we believe,
although this is somewhat speculative,
that there may have been a statue or portrait of the,
uh,
some of the grandson of Augustus,
son of a gripper Lucius Caesar in the pediment Illusia Caesar having died in,
uh,
in the year two.
Here's the view where we see the Roman Agora raw as it looks today,
the open space,
the columns around it.
Uh,
and you can also see it very curious building that looks very well preserved,
rising up on the eastern end,
uh,
a building in the shape of an octagon a and here's another view of the eastern
end showing that octagonal building more clearly.
This is the so called Oral Ogi on of Andronicus,
or as it is nicknamed the tower of the winds,
the tower of the winds,
which is easier to remember the tower of the winds.
Uh,
it's very controversial in date.
I dated here to the second half of the first century BC,
which is when I do believe that it dates,
but there are others who think otherwise.
And I'll tell you about that in a moment.
Here's a view that I took from the Acropolis,
uh,
showing the tower of the winds as it looks from up there as well as a closer
view of this amazing structure.
Again,
you can see how well preserved it is.
A,
you can see that it is indeed eight sided.
Uh,
you can see one of the porches,
there are two porches that had temple fronts with tri triangular pediments
columns below.
On those two sides.
There was also a staircase of that surrounded the structure.
Uh,
the,
what this was we believe is some kind of a clock tower,
a very inventive,
a clock tower.
And,
uh,
although again,
I think it was probably built in the [inaudible] period,
late republic,
uh,
John Camp,
who's an expert on things,
Athenian who wrote a book on the archeology of Athens,
who has been excavating the Greek Agora up since the 1970s,
uh,
and is a true expert of architecture in this part of the world.
He thinks the date is earlier than that.
He dates it to one 50 to 125 BC,
and he brings it into connection with the Ptolemies in Egypt,
the Ptolemaic rulers of Egypt because of their great interest in the telling of
time.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and the fact that they did have important connections with Athens during this
period.
I think he has a point.
He could be right.
Uh,
but I would add that,
um,
connections with Egypt were very strong,
uh,
in the late republic as well.
I mean,
keep in mind,
uh,
the,
fair between Julius Caesar and Cleopatra.
Keep in mind that we know that statues of Cleopatra and Marc Antony were put on
the Acropolis.
We know that there was a lot of interaction.
Cleopatra herself came to Athens.
So I don't think it's inconceivable that if one wants to connect this to things
Egyptian,
uh,
that one couldn't date it also to the [inaudible] area and period.
But whatever it's date,
it's fascinating in its own right.
Again,
because it's octagonal,
uh,
we've talked about the fact that we don't have octagon is in Rome until the time
of neuro.
Uh,
but we do see them.
we saw another example also in Leptin is Magdna the market there,
uh,
the Augustan period.
It's interesting to see this form emerging,
possibly under Ptolemaic influence.
Uh,
we're not sure,
uh,
emerging in the provinces before it seems to emerge in Rome itself.
And this,
this being another example,
here's a view of the monument again,
but also compared to a,
an engraving done by Stuart and Revet,
s t u a r t and r e v e t t Stewart.
And revet who made drawings of monuments that were in better shape and Athens in
the 18th century.
Uh,
and what this tells us,
besides showing us what the porch looked like,
a,
and you can see it well here,
it also shows us that there was a weather vane on the top that would have,
would have gone in the direction of the prevailing winds.
And the reason that we call this the tower of the winds is not only because of
that weather vane,
that one stood there,
but also because of the depictions of male,
uh,
personifications of the winds on all eight sides of the structure.
And those are extremely well preserved.
As you can see here,
a freeze of these male wins.
And if you look carefully at the Stuart and revet drawing,
you also see,
uh,
the,
that there was a sun dial on all eight sides of the monument.
So it's purpose,
needless to say,
to tell time the capitals,
uh,
from form those porches are these days,
Lotus leaves growing out of a cantus leaf.
So another Egyptian touch here,
uh,
this looking back to Egypt,
Egypt type capital's using them here,
the same kind of capitals that we noted turned up much later,
uh,
at the,
Severin a forum in leftist Magdna,
a detail of those winds and here a better detail of at least one of them to show
you what they look like close up.
And each one of them has a different attribute which has led scholars obviously
to speculate about which particular wind,
when,
which of the cardinal points of the compass,
which wind.
Uh,
they were,
uh,
in actuality we won't get into those arguments here,
but there's been a lot of time spent by scholars and trying to sort that out.
What is also interesting is the interior of the building,
which is also extremely well preserved.
And you can see here all in stone,
uh,
the way in which the octagon becomes a dome.
Uh,
and it has done extremely well.
and I mean this is,
this goes way beyond any kind of stone dome that we see either in a trust skin
or Roman architecture in Italy.
Uh,
and it shows us,
once again,
it underscores more.
Anything else I could show you the talent of these particular architects who had
been carving this Greek stone for centuries.
Uh,
the way in which they are able to make this transition from October tag and
we'll shape to a regular dome here is extraordinary.
They did not need concrete,
uh,
to create a great dome in this wonderful,
structure.
The Oral Ogi on event chronicus where the tower of the winds,
uh,
in,
in Athens.
The other great Phil Hellenic emperor was of course Hadrian.
We know Hadrian came to Athens on three occasions and we know the exact dates of
his visits.
One 20 for the first visit,
one 24 to 125 Hadrian was in Athens.
He came another time in one 28 and he came a third time and one 31 to one 32.
And all the buildings that are now going to show you a date to roughly to the
times of those three visits.
Uh,
the first one you see in an engraving here,
uh,
this was an aqueduct,
when Adrian came to Athens for the first time in one 24 to one 25.
He said,
we need to supply water to the people of Athens.
Uh,
and so he said,
he said,
uh,
he said his architects at work to build an aqueduct for Athens.
Uh,
they created a reservoir on Mount Lee Cabi toss that high,
the highest mountain in Athens,
a reservoir.
And then on the side,
one of the sides of the mountain facing the city,
uh,
they had,
a,
they built a kind of a structure,
uh,
that kind of a bridge that in part carried that water in to the city.
Uh,
it no longer survives or a couple of bases from it.
That's it.
Uh,
but we do fortunately have engravings,
uh,
that were made when it was in better shape when part of it's still stood.
Uh,
and we see one of those engravings here and what we can see right off
ionic capitals,
clearly based on those of the Eric theone.
So the Eric theone still a beacon for architects,
still a monument to be emulated,
emulated in the time of Hadrian as it was under Augustus.
We see an inscription and then we see something quite extraordinary.
If we look very closely above the right hand,
ionic capital,
we see the beginning of an RQ weighted lentil,
straight lentil,
the beginning of an Rqi Asian.
So what does that tell us?
That tells us clearly,
and here's a Stewart and revet drawing a of that element when it was in better
shape.
Again,
uh,
a straight lintel and RQ weighted Lindell with an inscription mentioning Hadrian
that is the same kind of RQ weighted lintel that we saw in to activity at the
Canopius that we saw in emphasis at the temple of Hadrian in emphasis showing
that this particular motif is RQ weighted Lindell.
Very much associated with Hadrian.
I says this is a Hadria Anik building essentially and used not just in Italy,
but elsewhere in the Roman world.
So again,
these,
these exchanges of ideas and motifs and artists and architects,
uh,
during the Adriatic period,
as was the case under Augustus.
Over here.
We're looking again from Google earth at the Roman Agora next to it,
a library of Hadrian,
a library that bears Hadrian's name,
ah,
that was also put up in Athens during the Adriatic periods,
specifically in 132 a d connected to the last visit that Hadrian made to Athens.
Uh,
we can see that it is a great,
a large open rectangular space with a the library itself at the upper most part
and then a,
a facade that has project and columns.
And I'll show that to you better in a moment.
Here's a view I took again from the Acropolis,
uh,
showing that open rectangular space.
As it looks today,
there's some later buildings built into it.
And here we're looking at the back wall of the facade,
which we'll see has projecting columns on it.
Ah,
here's a plan of the library of Hadrian of one 32 here on the right hand side of
the screen.
And you should be struck immediately as you look at this plan with its open
rectangular space with its with its,
um,
a pool here in the center with the columns going all the way around with an
entrance way in the front with projecting columns on that facade with a series
of niches that are alternating a segmental and rectangular,
uh,
with again,
the library located in that upper most part with other rooms forming a kind of
wing on either side.
This should remind you without any question of this.
And what is this Sam?
The forum pacas a forum of piece of the temple and pockets of Vespasian in Rome.
Uh,
so once again,
and it is a clear,
clear duplicate,
even though this is a library and this is a temple or a forum,
although we talked about the fact that we weren't absolutely sure how this was
used at may have been used as a kind of museum in Rome for the spoils and other
works of art.
Uh,
that Vespasian.
And the Flavian it's wanted to display.
But once again we are looking that they influenced does not flow only from
Greece to Rome,
but from Italy to Greece.
And in this case they are also using as a model for the library of Hadrian and
important building type in Rome.
They're using it,
you know,
perhaps for it in a different way.
Uh,
but nonetheless they are using almost that exact plan for this second century
building.
And I show you here a model of the library of Hadrian,
an Athens where we see that it was planted with greenery.
The library was located in the back.
There was a fairly conventional and France way.
I'm looking like a typical Greek temple.
Uh,
but then these columns,
that project in front of the wall was statuary on top looking very much like the
forum transitory IOM,
which you'll remember bordered the foreign Pakistan Roman.
That probably was also something that they were looking at a,
and here creating this is as far as the Greeks go to creating one of these
undulating walls with the projecting and receiving elements.
It's not,
it's,
it's still fairly conservative,
but nonetheless,
they've injected a little motion here using the traditional vocabulary of
architecture.
And here we see a I view of the wall of that facade,
of what survives of it today.
Uh,
the wall is made out of white pentelic marble and the columns are made of a
slightly,
I don't know if you can see it from where you sit,
but a slightly greenish tinge marble that comes from a place called Ingres
called Cara Stars,
k A.
So again,
this interest in varied marbles but varied marbles that come only from the very
rich quarries that Greece has a four,
they did not have to go anywhere else to get a high quality marble and to get
marble of a wide,
wide variety of colors.
I want to turn now to a structure that has one of the most complicated building
histories of any building I've shown you in the course of the semester.
Uh,
and I'll run through that relatively quickly.
This is the temple of Olympian Zeus,
the so called Olympia.
He on a,
that was put up or that was dedicated by Hadrian in the year 131 to 132 on the
tie on the occasion of his third visit to Athens.
Uh,
but it had again,
a very long building history.
It goes back to the archaic Greek period when it was begun.
It was begun by the so called Peisistratos.
I put these words on your monument list for you.
The sister who were Athenian tyrants,
they began to build it in the archaic period as a Doric temple.
Uh,
it was,
the construction was stopped.
However,
at the end of the sixth century BC in 510,
it was resumed in the Hellenistic period,
uh,
in 174 BC when Antiochus Epiphanes and his name is also on the monument and list
Antiochus Epiphanes a king of Syria,
uh,
decided to employ a Roman architect by the name of Kusudi Ious,
also on your monument list to finish the building.
A Roman architect.
That's interesting that we see a Greek Hellenistic rule or hiring a Roman
architects speaks to that exchange.
Again that is going on.
Uh,
he Kusudi is,
decides to use the Corinthian order,
the Corinthian order,
uh,
and he finishes it up to the architrave,
the building up to the architrave,
uh,
and,
um,
when Antiochus dies and one 64,
uh,
the,
that's where he's up to,
that's where that one 64,
they built the building up through the architrave using the Corinthian order,
Sola Saks,
Saks,
Athens,
and 86 BC.
And you'll remember what Sola does.
This is that very temple with the 55 foot tall columns that solar eyes and says,
I want those.
And he brings several of those back to Rome to be used in his renovation of the
temple of Jupiter.
Oh,
MC,
those very columns.
Uh,
it was,
it was the introduction of those Corinthian columns and capital's to Rome that
made that the most popular capitol in Rome.
And in the Roman Empire.
As we've seen,
Augustus wanted to complete the structure.
He did not do so,
and it was left to Hadrian to finish it.
And Hadrian finished it according to Kusudi as his plan in one 31 to one 32.
Uh,
and what Hadrian did was,
uh,
was,
put in this structure,
a statues of himself and the Zeus,
Zeus,
the Greek equivalent to Jupiter statues of Hadrian in one part of the structure
as to a Zeus and the other part of the structure and tons and tons,
lots and lots of statutes,
additional statues of Hadrian outside the temple in the court yard.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you see that you see this temple here as it,
as it,
as finished by Hadrian as it would've looked in the Adriatic period.
You can see that like a typical Greek temple as opposed to a Roman temple.
It does not have a facade orientation.
It has two entrance ways.
One with the statue of Hadrian,
one with a statue of Zeus,
and that it has columns,
and then circle the entire monument,
a peripheral colonnade as well as the staircase that goes all the way around.
So a typical Greek temple,
one 31 to one 32.
It's the same time that we see the temple of Venus and Roma going up in Rome.
What I described as a Greek import.
Hadrian is responsible for both.
Uh,
and so we see again this important interchange between the two at this
particular time,
a view of what survives of the Olympian.
It's columns,
it's Corinthian columns.
You can see the small people wandering around.
So this is a very large uh,
structure,
uh,
that I took from the Acropolis.
Once again,
here's a wonderful Google earth version of the Olympian and this combination of
what it looks like today with sort of this three d imaging that makes it look
also like it looked in antiquity.
Here you see some of the columns of the Olympia on the ones that still survived.
They are incredibly large and incredibly handsome.
And I think when you look at the high quality of the carving,
you are struck as I am at why the Romans decided the Corinthian order was the
order for them when they saw these,
these exact columns on the temple of Jupiter,
optimist,
Maximus,
capitol leanness and Rome.
When Hadrian made his visit to Athens in the,
in the last visit to Athens and the one thirties,
the city busily benefactors busily got together to put up an arch that would be
ready for Hadrian when he arrived and that he could parade through.
And that is the so called arch of Hadrian,
which you see here in a view of what it looks like today.
And in the Stewart and revet drawing on the right hand side of the screen,
again,
a quite conservative arch,
very simple single arcuate occupation in the center.
Pilasters done in,
uh,
with Corinthian order,
columns would have been added here.
A second story with a pediment,
no split pediment here.
Uh,
we see a straight,
you know,
conservative,
a pediment here and the Stuart and revet drawing tells us that in antiquity
there was a marble slab that was located in the center of that pedigree of that,
of that an addict.
In the second story,
and we know there were statues,
inscriptions,
tell us if there was statues on both sides of this.
And the statutes are very interesting because on the side that faced the ancient
Greek city,
there was a statute of Theseus and an inscription that said,
this is Athens,
the city of Theseus.
And on the other side,
of course,
ace,
they put up in order to pay obese since two,
our honor,
uh,
Hadrian and to try to extract favors from him,
undoubtedly they put up a statue to Hadrian on the other side.
And that inscription says,
uh,
this is the city of Hadrian,
not the city of Theseus.
I,
the last monument that I want to show you is a monument that is near and dear to
my own heart because in the two years that I lived in Athens,
in the 1970s,
I was working on a book on this particular monument.
The monument doesn't date to the Augustan period and it doesn't date to the
Adriatic period,
which makes it all the more interesting.
It dates to the time of Trajan and it has nothing to do with either of those two
emperors,
but with a man whose name is a mouthful.
And that is Gaius Julius Antiochus,
Epiphanes Phillip Papa's.
You don't have to remember all of that.
Uh,
I like to call him uncle Phil.
You can call him uncle Phil.
That's the easier way to refer to Gaius Julius Antiochus Epiphanes Phillip
Papa's,
uh,
nonetheless,
he was a very interesting man and we know a lot about his bio.
Uh,
we know,
for example,
that he was the son of a king of coma gene,
a Hellenistic kingdom in the eastern part of the empire in ancient Anatolia.
Uh,
what is now Turkey.
He was a son of that,
uh,
King of,
of a coma gene,
And that his relatives had been kings for some time.
Uh,
but he was unfortunate,
although he was slated to become king himself.
He was unfortunate that Vespasian the Roman Emperor Vespasian conquered Colma
gene made it a Roman colony depose the Kings,
uh,
and,
you know,
became ruler himself in a sense.
And so Phillip pop is because of the Romans never became king of coma.
Gene.
He seems to have made the best of it,
uh,
by,
by making his way to Rome,
uh,
using his influence and his high station as a deposed king to finagle for
himself,
uh,
a position as sue fact console in Rome.
What was a sue fact console?
A Suffolk console was kind of a console in waiting.
By that,
I mean that if one of the regular console's couldn't do his job,
the Suffolk console could be brought in as a substitute.
So Phillip Papa's could sort of stand and wait and hope that someone got sick
and he could come in or I've got,
you know,
was in war involved in military campaign and he would be called in to take his
place.
So he hangs around Rome for a while,
uh,
and then he eventually goes back,
goes to Athens,
he moves to Athens,
he's honored with all kinds of titles and Athens.
And he eventually ends up being dying in Athens and being buried in Athens.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I tomb gets put up in his honor between one 14 and one 16.
And we know the precise date because of an inscription on the monument,
there's still surviving monument that makes reference to some of Trajan is
titles,
titles that Trajan held between one 14 and one 16,
but does not include titles that he got after that.
So we know that it was put up between one 14 and one 16 and we're going to see
that it features a freeze,
uh,
depicting Phillip Aarp is at the high point of his life.
His pro cassis console rs is consular procession.
And when he was made a console in Rome,
I show you a view from the air where you see once again the Acropolis and the
relationship of the Acropolis to the Moose.
They on hill,
the hill of the muses.
Now what's most extraordinary is that there is only one ancient monument on the
Moosejaw on hill,
and that is the monument of Uncle Phil.
We are standing on the Acropolis.
Uh,
we are.
Look this,
I love this picture.
I took this picture of myself and I'm very proud of it because it just happens
to work,
especially because these two guys happened to be standing there taking pictures
of the Odeon uh,
of roadies.
Attic is here,
but we're standing here,
we're looking back toward the Moosejaw on hill and you can see not quite at the
apex,
but almost near the apex apex,
the monument,
the sole monument that stands on this hill,
the monument of Uncle Phil.
How did he rate,
uh,
to be able to get the so monument on one of the three major hills?
You can see it in his marble.
You can see it popping up until like marble.
You can see it popping up almost near the apex of the hill.
If we look at this site plan,
you will see that it is sited.
Exactly.
You see it here on the top of the hill of the muses cited exactly in
relationship to the Acropolis.
Lined up with what building the Eric Theone,
the Eric Theone,
this building that was so revered by the Romans.
It's lined up exactly with an at mid point between the proper layer and the
Parthenon.
Exactly on the uh,
Eric theone and this is the view here.
We are standing right in front of Uncle Phil's monument looking back at the
Acropolis.
Even if you don't,
if you don't want to go see uncle Phil,
which I hope you will if you're an Athens,
visit him for me.
I hope that you will stay at the very least you want to stand there with your
back to Phil's monument and look at the Acropolis.
You get one of the best views of the Acropolis from the Moosejaw on hill.
You see it here and your view is lined up exactly with the Eric theone.
Now why is uncle Phil buried on this hill?
Uh,
this is interesting because if you think back to,
to market texture that we've looked at in the course of this semester,
we didn't see people buried on hills.
The Romans don't vary.
People on hills,
they bury people on flat ground outside the walls of the city and they're
necropolis is every tune we've seen was on flat essentially on flatland.
Why is uncle Phil built buried in a tomb near the apex of the hill?
While as I was writing this book,
I looked back to his own ancestors,
uh,
two people in this part of the world,
to,
uh,
a group of dynamics in a place called Nimrah dog,
also in Anatolia.
And I show you one of their WellPreserved tombs here.
Uh,
and you can see,
uh,
that,
the tomb is built not quite,
not at the apex of the hill,
but on the slope of the hill.
Uh,
in this case,
not,
not as close as uncle Phil's is to the apex,
but moving on that,
uh,
moving up on that slope toward the apex.
And if you look very carefully at this monument,
you will see among the remains,
some seated statues of the dynamics of a red dog of this part of this,
this area,
uh,
that Phillip Papa's also comes from.
This is the Phillip Papa's monument on the lefthand side of the screen as it
looks today,
made out of pentelic marble,
beautifully carved.
It is a kind of a tower tomb with a plain base,
a curved,
a second story that has the scene of Phillip Papas and the chariot and the time
of his constantly procession.
And then,
uh,
some statues in niches,
seated statues looking very much like those of numbered dog up above.
We think it's Phillip Papas and self with a bare chest headless in the center of
figure at a Toga over here.
And certainly a another figure flanking him,
another male seated figure on the right hand side of the screen.
Why do I show you the arch of Titus in connection to this?
Because we know that Phillip,
Papa's his father and uncle,
uh,
participated in the Jewish wars on the side of the Flavian emperors in order to
gain,
even though they'd been deposed,
they wanted to gain favor with them.
Uh,
and when Phillip Papa's went to Rome,
this is a monument that he would have seen this monument that demission put up
two of those Jewish wars that his father and his uncle had participated in on
the Veolia with that representation of Titus in a chariot.
And I think there's no question,
and I present this in the book as a theory,
that the precast is constant Alaras Phillip op is closely based on the triumphal
scene of,
uh,
of,
of Titus.
And perhaps it's no coincidence we don't have too many pentelic marble buildings
in Rome.
The arch of Titus is made out of Greek pentelic marble.
Is that a coincidence?
I don't think so.
Here's a restored view of the monument of Phillip Papa's as it would've looked
in antiquity,
the base,
the concealer procession,
the statue of Uncle Phil in the center of the inscription to the left,
to the the pilaster that survives with the inscription making reference to trade
ins,
titles that allow us to date it.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
probably a missing attic with an inscription at the upper most part.
This view and this view over here shows you some graffiti that fortunately since
it's been erased,
I show you the interior of the,
or what survives of the back wall.
That would have been the burial chamber.
Here's a restored view showing that burial chamber,
the Sarcophagus of Phillip Papa's where his remains would have been placed,
a statue of him on a console that still survives and then columns and f and a
straight lintel that formed what we call a Nice Goss and a I s,
k,
O,
s which served as a kind of shrine,
uh,
to honor him on the inside of the monument.
And if we look at this cross section of the tomb,
which was which,
which are in my book,
we see the sarcophagus,
we see the statue of Phil and we see the way in which it is lined up with the
representations of Phillip op is on the outside in his chest,
kind of midway between the scene of him in his chariot and the scene of him with
the newt within,
with the bare chest and heroic nudity.
So during his lifetime in the consular per session after death up above,
so honored three times in three statues on this monument.
Here's a view of some of the figures that accompany him.
They're wearing Roman togas because the scene is taking place in Rome.
That's where the constant or procession is.
They're carrying,
uh,
foss gaze,
like the body guards do for an emperor.
And that to a shows the relationship of this to the arch of Titus.
Here we see the scene of the arch of Titus triumph and the scene of Phillip
Papa's triumph.
Uh,
clearly the one on the right in my mind based on the one on the left,
if you look at details of the chariot and you see a Nice Goss,
again decorating the chariot and Nice Gos that has a figure of none other than
Hercules,
we can see him wearing the holding a club.
So once again,
just like car color,
we see in this case earlier,
uh,
Phillip pop is associating himself with Hercules.
If we look at a detail of his head,
which is fortunately not that well preserved,
we see that he is bearded.
We see he wears a raid crown.
So although he is represented in this constant of procession,
his kingly what he,
that he might've been a king is referred to,
but also,
uh,
his triumph over death.
If we look at sculpture from Nim were dog.
Uh,
we see once again this interesting reliefs and there's more than one of these,
of dynastic number dog shaking hands with Hercules,
with his club,
and wearing a raid crown.
So this is another one of these wonderful examples of this fertile mix that one
gets so often in provincial Roman art where you see a,
a monument clearly based in part on Roman precedents,
but also based on the bio of this particular man and,
and more local precedents to see a scene of a Phillip Papa's in the upper most,
uh,
the upper most area showing him in heroic nudity.
And the last image that I want to show you is just to make the point that
interestingly enough,
this monument was put up by Phillip pop is a sister,
a woman by the name of Belle Billa,
Bal B,
I.
L l a and Bell Billa.
I mean,
I sh I wanted to make this point because we have seen so few examples.
It's not that there were none,
but they were small in comparison to those of men that vary.
There are many fewer women,
uh,
seem to have put up monuments than men.
But the examples that we have are very interesting indeed.
Uh,
and in this case,
we know that the tomb was put up by Bell Bella,
a woman who became very friendly with Sabina wife of Hadrian.
In fact,
the three of them travel together to Egypt to themes,
uh,
to see the Colossi of Memnon,
which I show you up there.
And Bell bill leaves an inscription when she goes that she was there.
Uh,
so she tells us that.
So a very,
just to close today,
a very interesting example of an extraordinary,
a tomb in Athens,
but one that was built by a woman.
And I think that's a great way to end on this beautiful Thursday.
Thank you all.